are you a fan of mmo's but only play on
consoles well then I've got some good
news because action MMO tera is on its
way the ps4 and Xbox one this year I'm
Matt this is a GameSpot news update and
make sure to LIKE and subscribe stay up
to date on all of your MMO gaming news
Tara will operate as a free to play game
with microtransactions on the ps4 and
Xbox one this is how the game currently
works on pc but developer blue bull has
announced that its reworked the MMO to
work with the DualShock 4 and xbox one
controller tara builds itself it's the
only MMO that offers true action combat
so it'll be interesting to see how that
translates to console more information
about Tara's console Edition will be
revealed in the coming months a closed
beta is on its way and you can register
for right now on the games website we'll
keep you up to date as mores revealed if
you want some videogame action right now
check out our video on taking down the
Guardians in Zelda breath of the wild
[Music]
[Music]